la visita del jefe de la diplomacia
saudí a Damasco es un paso más para el
restablecimiento de las relaciones con
Siria que ha estado aislada durante más
de 12 años por la guerra civil al
encuentro de hoy entre el príncipe
faisal bim faraj y su homólogo sirio
faisal precede una visita del ministro
de exteriores sirios arriat el jueves
pasado cabe puntualizar que estos
encuentros bilaterales son meramente
diplomáticos Es decir para restablecer
los servicios consulares y los vuelos
entre ambos países por lo que las
expectativas de Damasco devolver a la
liga árabe no están contempladas este
fin de semana se celebra una cumbre en
riat donde los ministros exteriores
árabes acordaron seguir trabajando para
encontrar una solución política al
conflicto de Siria pero Damasco no tiene
apoyos para ser otra vez miembro de este
organismo pan árabe cabe recordar que el
presidente basharelasad ha estado
recuperando todo el territorio nacional
gracias al apoyo militar Irán Rusia y la
milicia gesbola del Líbano mientras que
la posición ha tenido el apoyo de las
monarquías del Golfo y de Egipto también
es un factor importante Israel que se
siente amenazado porque las armas
iraníes están en suelo sirio